MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Hey there, everybody,
and welcome to CST 103.
I'm Mark Mirchandani, developer
advocate at Google Cloud.
And today, we're
going to be talking
about what's new in Google
Cloud cost management.
We'll go over a brief tour of
the different cost management
tools that are available to you.
And we'll look at what's
changed over the past year.
Now, we've got a
lot to cover, so I'm
going to go ahead
and get started.
First things first.
This URL is where you
can view the billing
notes for all the different
releases that have happened.
We're going to go over the ones
that happened in the last year.
But if you need a text
version or if you just
want to see the changes,
make sure to keep
an eye on that you URL.
So when you talk
about cost management,
we're really talking about
the three key pillars--
understand, control,
and optimize.
So understanding
your cost is all
about being able to see how
your costs are being generated
and where they're trending.
Controlling your cost
is really about reducing
the risk of
overspending and being
able to improve the
predictability of your costs.
Optimizing is really more
about focusing on overspending.
Again, control is
about controlling it.
Optimizing is really about
eliminating it and then
reducing waste through
some of the recommendations
that Google Cloud
provides and finding ways
that you can get the same
performance for lower cost.
We're going to look
at all three of these.
But before we can
dive into that,
we really need to look at how
to organize your resources.
And I don't want to spend
too much time on the resource
hierarchy.
But I highly recommend
you go and check out
last year's next talk on
the resource organization
and access management.
It's a really great talk, and
it dives into a lot of detail.
But the overall summary is
that you want your resource
hierarchy to look a lot
like your organization.
You can see an example here.
But as you're
trying to dive down
into who has access
to what projects,
you can use folders
to break that out.
The permissions are
inherited downwards.
You also want to be
able to track your costs
through this same hierarchy.
So you want to
understand which groups
are paying for which
resources or which projects
fall under which categories.
It's really important to
be able to track that,
because as your
organization grows,
you're going to want to
be able to say, how do I
know who paid for what?
Another really great feature
you can use is project label.
So you can create another way
of looking at your projects.
And you might label them with,
first say, your environments,
right?
So you might have a production
environment and a development
environment.
And then you can
say the same thing.
How can I get my costs for
my production environment?
Well, you can grab all the
costs for those labels.
So it's really important
to have those organized.
And speaking of
permissions, you're
going to see a lot of
permissions for the billing
account themselves.
I want to go over the roles that
you're typically going to see.
But it's also important to
know that you can actually
create custom roles with
the different permissions
that you need.
And you want to always follow
that security best practice
of least privilege.
So making sure that people
only have the access
they need and nothing more.
So you can create
custom roles for that
as you go down the road.
But to start with, you're
going to have billing account
administrators,
viewers, and users.
Viewers are only going to
be able to see the cost
on the billing account.
So it's a great
simple role for them
to go ahead and see how
much people are spending.
Users are actually able
to associate a project
with a billing account.
And that's really
important that you only
give that to trusted
users because, as, again,
as your organization
grows, you're
going to have a lot of projects.
And being able to add them
to the billing account
means that you're actually
going to have to pay for them.
So make sure that you have
the right permissions set up
and that only certain
users can add projects
to the billing account.
Finally, you're going to
have the administrator who
is going to be able
to control everything
like an administrator would.
And it actually is going
to be the focus of most
of the things we're talking
about today because they're
the ones who can look at
all the different reports
in the console, as well
as being the ones you
can contact support.
So you're going
to probably start
with using those three roles.
You might add more
roles as you go on.
The other thing that's
important to note
is that a project
owner can see the costs
for only their projects, right?
So they'll have access to the
billing section of a console.
And they'll be able to
see the billing reports.
But it'll only show data
for their specific projects.
You can use that
to your advantage
when you're setting up
the permissions for users
to be able to understand
who can see what.
So with your costs being
able to be measured only
because your resources
are organized
and because you have
these permissions,
let's move on to the first
step, which is really
understanding your costs.
And the best way to
understand your cost
is going to be to go to the
billing section of the Google
Cloud console.
And as soon as you
do, you're going
to see this which is the
billing account overview.
This page looks a lot different
than it did a year ago.
And there's been a
ton of changes to it.
We're going to step
through some of now.
But needless to say, it's
an overview page, right?
So you can see a lot of
really quick information
about your billing account
as soon as you go there.
The first section we'll
look at is this new chart
that actually is two
new charts that show up
that show you your top five
projects and your top five
products that you're
spending costs on.
And it shows you their actual
cost and their forecasted cost.
So, I mean, as far as going
to your billing account
and seeing important
information,
you're going to be able to
see where your costs are,
where they're going
over the month.
Just being able to see that
quick view is really helpful.
In addition to that, we've also
added a billing health card.
So this is a card that
uses some of the best
practices for our customers
and says, hey, maybe you
want to apply these to
your billing account
so that you're able to stay on
top of, well, the health of it.
So one of the great
examples of this
is being able to set up a
budget, which we'll actually
talk about in a little
bit or making sure
that you turn on BigQuery
export or billing data export
to BigQuery.
We'll also talk
about that later.
And then one of the other
good recommendations
is to have multiple billing
account administrators.
This can be really important
because, as I mentioned before,
billing account administrators
are the ones who
can contact support.
So it's really
critical to make sure
that you have hopefully at
least two, but maybe more.
And you have this idea of a
reasonable level of redundancy,
right?
You don't want too many
people having access
to your billing account.
But you also want to make
sure that if one person gets
locked out, you're
not completely stuck.
So one of the first reports
that I want to talk about here
is a new one that's
been launched.
And it's the cost
breakdown report.
And this really just gives you a
quick and easy-to-see breakdown
of the net impact of
all the things you're
spending, how the different
discounts or other spendings
affected those, and
then your final cost.
This is a great and
very simple chart
to be able to look at
any month and understand,
here's what I spent.
Here, all the different
Google Cloud discounts.
And there's a lot of different
ones that can happen.
And then here's what I'm going
to end up actually paying.
Besides that, there's
the billing cost table.
Also, all of this is going to
be available on the console.
And one of the reasons that all
of these pages have been added
is because a lot of this data
has actually been removed
from the Google Cloud invoices.
So there's a lot
less data there.
The invoice is really more about
here's how much I need to pay.
All of these tables and
charts are much more about
how those costs
actually came to be.
And the billing cost data is
really inside the billing cost
table is really
just a tabular view
of all of your invoice costs.
And it's grouped by the SKU.
You can quickly filter
by different projects.
You can do services, SKUs,
you can rearrange the columns,
it's a really great and simple
way to break down all the costs
and see how they're grouped.
You can also export it
to a CSV if you need
to do some offline analysis.
But this is probably
the first place
where you'll be able to see
all those costs broken down.
Similar to that table,
there's the pricing report.
And the pricing report,
it looks very similar.
But the difference here is
that this one is actually
showing you the cost of
all the different services
that Google Cloud has.
That actually
includes Google Cloud.
And it includes Google
Maps Platform and G Suite.
So they're all
available in that table.
And similar to the
billing cost report,
you can move things around.
And you can break
it down as you need.
But you're also able to select
to show all the SKUs for Google
Cloud or just showing the
SKUs that you've used.
So it's a quick way to get the
pricing for all of that data.
On top of, if you have a
negotiated price with Google
Cloud, it's going to
show you the default list
price, the negotiated price
and the discount there.
So it's really,
really helpful to be
able to say, OK, well, these
are all the services cost.
And just like that
billing report,
you can export it to
a CSV so that you're
able to see all that data and
do some offline analysis as
needed.
Now, the Billing documents page
is a fairly straightforward
page.
It's really just where you go to
download invoices, statements.
It used to be called
the Invoices page.
It's been renamed
and cleaned up.
And, again, it's really
just about finding that data
and downloading it.
This is where you're going
to get the hard copy for all
those documents.
The billing reports,
the actual chart
that you're seeing
on the screen here,
this is part of the
Billing reports page.
And this is probably
where you're
going to want to spend
most of your time, right?
It gives you a great way to
visualize all of the data
that we were looking at before.
The table is great because it
breaks down into great detail.
But it can be a little
hard to digest, right?
The visualization here
is really helpful.
And it shows you the
transactional costs
on a per day basis.
And you can actually break it
between a line chart and a bar
chart.
But there's a lot of
options on this page.
And that's where you'll be
measuring a lot of your costs.
So one of the new features
here is the cost forecast.
And this has been added and
changed a couple of times
over the past year.
And it includes a
long-term cost trend.
So now it includes
up to 12 months.
And it factors in things
like sustained use discounts.
So sustained use
discounts typically
start off with a
very low discount.
And then as you go along,
the sustained use discount
kicks in.
And you get this
downwards pattern.
And then the next month starts.
And it goes back up.
So the forecasting takes
all of that into effect
and gives you a great idea of
where all that information is
and what you'll be spending
over the next 12 months.
In addition to that, the right
side of the billing reports,
there's all these filters
on the right side.
And you can drill down into
any specific components
that you want.
When you change
these components,
it will actually
add it to the URL.
And then if you make a
custom report or something,
you can just share
that URL with others.
So it's really easy to
drill down into an area
and then share that with
the rest of your team.
There's also been a
lot of new features
that have been added
to the filters.
And one of the cool ones
is the invoice-centric view
that you can click on.
So in the default
view, you can select
whatever range you want--
last 30 days, 90 days,
or just custom ranges.
And that's really helpful.
But the invoice view
just tailors it directly
to your invoice, right?
So show me the
invoice for June--
show me the invoice for
August or June and August.
And, again, it breaks
down that chart
so you can see the information
and the costs there.
But it really just lets
you say, OK, well here's
all the cost for that month and
how it compares to my invoice.
In addition to
that filter, we've
added a couple other ones.
This one's really cool.
It's location filter, right?
So now you can actually
break down your costs
by where they came
from, what geography,
what region, or
multi-region area.
All of those are
available here--
just a really helpful way
to break down the costs.
In addition to that,
we've got labels.
We talked about
project labels before.
And these are
resource labels where
you're able to do the
same thing, all right.
Let's take a compute engine
instance or multiple instances
and label them all
with production.
And now, in the billing cost
reports, you can actually say,
show me all those production
instances and the costs
they generated--
really, really helpful
to be able to drill down
into that level of detail.
So I mentioned this
before in the health card.
But what you want to do--
and here's a feature, right?
You just go to the
Billing reports page.
You enable the
export to BigQuery.
And what you want to
do is turn that on.
If you haven't done it so
right now, pause, and then go
do it because it's
really, really important.
It actually doesn't take data
from before you turn it on,
which is why it's so
important that you probably
want to go enable it now.
But this exports all the billing
data at a very granular level.
Some of the changes that
have happened recently
is now going to it's hourly.
So it has a start
hour and an end hour.
And then it's all the
costs that have happened
for all of the different things
associated with that billing
account.
It is the most granular
data you're going to get.
A BigQuery, of course,
is a great place
to do data analysis
and store data.
So it's really, really
helpful to have that there.
But you can always
export it out of BigQuery
if you need to hook it up
to a third-party tool or BI
or whatever.
It's really helpful to have.
And that's why it's so
important to make sure
that you enable
it, because you're
going to want to be able
to see that level of detail
when you do any
future cost modeling
or really just to get that
level of analysis on your costs.
So all of that really
focuses on the ways
to understand your costs.
I want to talk about
the biggest way
to control your costs, right?
Viewing them is great.
But being able to control
them is also very important.
And we're going to
talk about budgets.
So budgets are probably
the number one tool
to actually implement
cost controls.
And they're really flexible.
They're actually
very powerful too.
So let's go ahead
and break it down.
Starting with budgets,
the first thing you can do
is, well, you just
set up a budget.
And when you set
up a budget, say,
let's say $1,000
budget, when you
hit that amount, it's
going to send an email out
to billing administrators
saying, hey,
you hit this budget.
But you can actually
configure multiple thresholds
because you want to know
maybe before you hit $1,000.
So when you set up a budget,
you actually set a threshold.
And you'll say 50% of $1,000
and then 100% of $1,000.
But you can also set up
forecasted thresholds.
So forecasted thresholds
are about when
Google Cloud predicts that
you're going to hit that cost,
right?
And that can be
really helpful to stay
on top of any surprises.
So if you're three
days into the month,
and you get an
email saying that,
hey, Google Cloud
thinks you're going
to spend 100% of your
$1,000 budget, that
might be a call to action
to go do something.
So as you set up a budget,
set up multiple thresholds.
And you can set up
multiple budgets
as well because
you're going to want
to be able to track
different things.
Speaking of that,
you can actually
set up filters on the budget.
So the budget by default is
the entire billing account.
But when you actually
filter it down,
you can choose specific
projects, specific products.
Or you can even choose
those resource labels
that we talked about earlier
and say, OK, well, show me.
Here's my production budget.
Here's my dev budget.
Here is the budget for
all of my biz dev project.
You have that flexibility
and that control
to be able to say, well, here,
we'll get different alerts
for different people.
The other thing I want to
talk about is the Budget API.
So this is currently in beta.
But what it lets
you do is automate
the creation and managing
of those budgets.
That's really important
because, as you grow
and your organization gets
more and more complex,
you probably don't want
to do all of this by hand.
So being able to
spend some time,
learn the Budget API
is really, really
critical to being able to
say, OK, well, I set up
a new project.
We're going to go ahead
and automate and add that
to budgets and create
new budgets and so on.
So spending some time here can
be really valuable as you grow.
So we've talked about budgets
being able to send out emails
to billing administrators.
But oftentimes, you want to send
emails to other people as well.
And that's where
this new feature
comes in that can
actually let you add up
to five emails per budget
through cloud monitoring.
And it's actually
pretty straightforward.
You just go into the budget.
You click on the little checkbox
that says cloud monitoring.
You're going to
set up a channel.
And then you just
add emails to that.
An important note here is
that while you can just
add five individual
emails, you might
want to consider adding a
group email instead, right?
So that way instead of sending
it to one person in accounting,
you're sending it to a group in
accounting or to a biz dev team
or whatever, because you
want to be able to say, here,
send these budget alert
emails to this team.
But you don't want to have
to constantly add people
to the team to
the budget, right?
So it's much easier to
manage the team in something
like G Suite and then just have
that send out to that group.
And then you can leave
the budgets alone.
So it's a great way to
add additional people
to your budget.
Now, that's the
basics of budgets.
But the real power
of budgets come
from what we call programmatic
budget notifications.
And this is really cool
because it basically
lets you hook up your
budget to Pub/Sub.
And Pub/Sub in this case
is an event handler.
And it's going to take
alerts from the budget.
And they'll send them off to
wherever you want them to be.
And we've got some sample
code in the documentation
that actually looks at
sending it to Cloud Functions.
But when you create
a budget, you just
click that box-- very simple.
You choose a Pub/Sub topic,
or you make a new one.
And then you can go off and
make your Cloud Function.
And we've got some
sample code like I said.
A very popular example of
this is sending a budget
notification to Slack, right?
So whenever you're on
an update on your budget
comes in, go put it
in a Slack channel
and have an update there.
Simple, but it's
just a notification.
So when you have Google Cloud
Functions and other systems
in Google Cloud,
you can do whatever
you could do with code.
And that's really important
because you can actually
do more advanced
things, like, let's say
you hit way higher on your
budget than you expected.
You could actually
shut down projects.
You could shut down resources.
There's some sample code for
detaching a billing account
from a project.
That's a really
dangerous thing to do,
because when you remove
the billing account
for the project, any paid
resource on that project
might get shut down in
a very unexpected way.
So be really careful about that.
But it's a great starting point
to understand how do I really
control my resources?
And, again, it comes down
to your organization.
What's important for
your organization?
How do those budgets come
up for your organization?
And then what kind
of responses can you
have to really putting
controls in place?
So programmatic
budget notifications
are really going to be
the most powerful way
to put cost controls
in your place.
So talked about understanding,
talked about control.
Let's talk about
optimizing cost, right?
This is the great one
because basically, you're
going to end up saving money.
And hopefully you're going to
do it without changing anything.
And honestly, one of the
more common things I see
is that people aren't taking
advantage of committed use
discounts.
And this is such a huge
and actually really easy
thing to set up on your account.
All you have to do
is sign up for them.
And you'll start to pay a lot
less for some of the resources
you already use.
So committed use discounts
or sometimes we call them
CUDs are able to help
you save on really
great static workloads.
So if you've got VCPUs, RAM,
SSDs, GPUs, all of those
at a static level, you can
look at and say, OK, well,
I'm running a good
amount of that.
Or maybe I have a
baseline of it, right?
You might have spiky workloads.
But if you've got
that baseline, you
can take them out and purchase
a committed use discount
for that amount.
And then you're just going
to be paying a lot less
for the same thing.
You're not changing
those resources at all.
You're just getting
a discounted price
because you're signing up for
a one or three-year commitment
based on that.
So it's really helpful to have.
It's really easy to set up.
And I've actually just added
[? Invada, ?] the committed use
discounts for Cloud SQL.
The database is
probably not something
you're spinning
up and down a lot.
You probably have a
good baseline for that.
So it's just another great
way to save a lot of money.
And we actually have the
Committed Use Discount Analysis
Report now, again, available
in the Billing section, which
lets you just visualize
your usage, right?
So in this case, you
have a very static usage.
It'll show you what you're
using on a committed use
discount, what you
could be using,
and what's eligible for it.
And then you can
say, well, look,
I've got this flat
workload that's
going to be running for a year.
Why don't I save money on?
Very easy way to save money.
And, again, no changes
really necessary
to your actual resources
that are running.
So the other thing that
changed in the last year
with committed use discounts
is discount sharing.
And this one is
probably my favorite
because what it lets you do is
take committed use discounts
and move them to a
billing account level.
If you've worked
with them before,
they were specific to a project.
So you have committed
use discount
on this project and one
on this and this and this.
And as you grow on projects,
that can be pretty painful.
So it's really great to be
able to say, all the billing,
all the committed
use discounts are now
at the billing account level--
much, much easier
and easier to say,
oh, let's just spread it
across all our projects.
Highly recommend
you check that out
if you're using committed use
discounts because it's just
an even easier
way to save money.
One of the other features
that's rolled out now
and is going to have a lot
of changes coming to it
soon is the
Recommender Hub which
is part of an Active Assist.
It's currently in beta.
And it surfaces a lot
of recommendations.
So you'll see some
security recommendations.
But you'll also see some
cost recommendations.
And two of the great ones
are a committed use discount
recommendation.
So the analysis report
lets you see it.
But this one will just
tell you, look, hey, look,
you're spending a lot here.
You could be saving money there.
And then another
[INAUDIBLE] recommendation
is the Compute Engine cross
family recommendations.
So when you're using
Compute Engine,
you've got to analyze
which family you're using,
which sizes you're using.
That can get pretty complicated.
And this will basically
measure the amount
that you're using those
and say, oh, look, this
is a pretty memory-intensive
application you're running.
You might want to
consider switching
to a memory-optimized machine.
And you'll end up
saving a lot of money.
There's a lot of great stuff
coming to the Recommender Hub,
so make sure to keep
your eye on that.
So with all of
that being said, we
talked about understanding,
controlling, and really
optimizing your cost.
There's two great sessions that
are also available this week--
CST 101 and CST 104.
You can see a great
customer story
of how they used these
recommendations to save money
on a whole bunch
of other stuff--
definitely recommend
you check that out.
And if you're interested
in learning more,
you want it set up to this
URL-- cloud.google.com/cost
management, because all of the
resources that we talked about
and so much more are there.
You've got resources,
guides, Qwiklabs,
YouTube playlist--
a bunch of stuff
that really deep dives on
these individual topics.
So I know it was a lot.
But thank you all so
much for joining me.
And don't forget to enable
billing export to BigQuery.
Thank you.